wow
look who's back it's the us against all
the odds
everything's stacked against us possibly
in the world
but uh here we are once again on a
beautiful friday
or should i say an apocalyptic friday
really not that beautiful
at least in california but it is a
friday it's beautiful somewhere
actually i was talking to um actually i
don't know if i should say that but
i was talking to a friend who isn't who
usually lives in california but is
somewhere else
and he sent me pictures and it was very
beautiful there
so it's beautiful somewhere okay yeah um
guys you may notice that i'm rocking
wiki feet
hat so it's not that they're a sponsor
of the show
they're not trust me um it's just that
it so happens that i am number two
on the whole website for most beautiful
feet and so i thought it would be
appropriate
to come here and say you know
rep represent basically that i'm number
one but we have an issue
because if you guys watched our last
episode with bobby lee
you'll know that
we begged you guys to please help a
brother out
and raise his foot score which was which
was paris
period paris periodically low
no paris what is it perilously low
perilously low and
actually it went down a bit because when
i was checking yesterday
this guy had a 6.2
he was beyond so far beyond perfection
he had a 6.2 out of 5 a score i had
never seen in my life
um how do you go above five yeah i don't
know their rating systems
pretty epic i love that it allows you to
go beyond five yeah
and so bobby did that
and what's funny is if you go to like
let's see
celebrities that's me obviously
sight rating
uh sort by sight rating you'll see bobby
lee
is literally number one on the website
and number two and number two is ethan
klein
but see what happened is that i played
myself
i totally played myself the girls the
first shot
the first shot they have is of me there
isn't even a foot
in it oh you can't i guarantee you
there's a foot in it
yeah but um cool but i want to smell
feet
well i'm a little do not well i'm happy
that i was able to move
mountains for bobby i'm a little upset
that he passed me so what i'd like to
see from you guys
obviously i want to still make good on
our promise but here we've got
5.9 oh i'm not logged in
here we got a 5.9 can we move him down
maybe to 5.5
obviously an outstanding score i'd like
him to be number two on the website not
number one you know what i mean yeah
so if we maybe we just need people to
ride a little harder for my feet because
i feel like i need to be the undisputed
king of this [ __ ] we just need everyone
to coordinate so
don't don't downvote him too much maybe
i just need more votes
yeah don't go crazy but we need him be
number two beautiful talking about
subtle stuff
subtle moves it's a coordinated movement
yeah maybe not not ones but like maybe a
few fours we'll get them there right you
know what i mean
subtle stuff just a couple here and
there yeah
but here's the thing like crims chris
hemsworth is technically
has the most beautiful feat let's take a
look at this idiot
[Laughter]
i mean
who cares barely even sorry i can't
really tell yeah
yeah these people are desperate they're
ranking us feet from 100 feet away
i give you a foot shot straight up to
the camera i can't even see his feet
what are you talking about
anyway i want to talk about feet i love
that chris hemsworth is number three
behind
you yeah he's nice
yeah it's awesome it is awesome but then
then i ran into another issue which i
really need to discuss with you guys
being you know popularity if you sort by
popularity
i'm not even on what i'm not even here
popularity is based on vote voting
volume
for example shawn mendes apparently a
lot of people like to jerk off to his
feet
wait so how does he end up being number
one he has 436
total votes right how many did you have
and so what we need we need to be most
popular and most beautiful
is what i'm saying so you have less
votes in total
yes i'll tell you how much i said like
430 so what here was what we need from
you guys okay
let me set them out the bar for you guys
and we'll show these guys what game the
website crashed oh no we crashed this
website but it works so wait
we see we only have 185 i mean we need
like another 200 volts
to clinch this thing
we can do that yeah i think so too
especially we'll keep that we'll keep it
going i mean
this is a this is important to me and
uh this is important to me i just wonder
if they're gonna ban you
why would they do that i'm the best
thing that ever happened to wikipedia
nobody was even on this website
i don't think anyone has even ever
bought their hat before and we bought
like six of them yeah we bought we
bought one for everybody
in the in the gang yeah i'm rock yeah
so welcome everybody just a little
housekeeping obviously you know
you know certain podcasts they talk
about important things
at the beginning of the show um
thank you to all of our beautiful
members who make this
episode possible this is the extra
episode h3
after dark
you know there's certain things that
come across our desks
from week to week and we say this [ __ ]
is gonna get us
age restricted it's gonna get us
demonetized it's gonna get mature rated
and now
instead of throwing those in the bin we
say thank you to our members
we are going to throw it all together
into a stew
of pimple popping [ __ ] no wiping
whatever it is so thanks to our members
and to
you guys for making it possible we love
doing this this episode and we love you
guys as well so thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you with peace
and love
man that bobby lee being number one on
the website did give me a kick though i
will tell you
good job everybody oh there's one other
thing i want to address before we get
into it
so on the last episode there when bobby
and kalila started talking about like uh
they started talking about like their
sex lives and role playing and stuff
yeah and so what we do there is that we
blurred it and said oh well this is
available for members
you did a man shapiro i did kind of do a
bench bureau
yeah you're right i did i realized that
afterwards which is awesome
but let me tell you let me explain the
process at least so you understand
we submit these videos there's a there's
a program in youtube to get your videos
certified and rated so that the rating
can't get
unflipped by a random rater and so by
the system we submit our videos
and then they'll either say okay it's
all good it's green and it's good to go
or they'll say in in this case they send
it back and they say
this part this conversation
will turn your video it's like not even
yellow but mature rated which means
it will get a lot less views and so what
we would usually do is cut it out
entirely and just say well [ __ ] that
then you know it sucks but whatever
but now we can leave it in in its
entirety
for the members and so
it's not like you know you're
basically it wouldn't exist at all if it
weren't for the member of content you
wouldn't even know
it existed and so i think it's cool that
that
you guys are still able to watch that
content um
over there personally so that's what
that is i hope that makes sense
let's talk about poop
i don't know why all roads always lead
to poop yeah i'm shocked that you want
to talk about that did that
make sense my explanation oh yeah yeah
basically basically otherwise we would
have had to cut it so
yeah with the membership we can keep it
for members
yeah i guess maybe some people were
upset thinking
you know we were purposely holding
something back in order to incentivize
joining up but that's not really the
case it would just it just wouldn't
exist otherwise so
which have happened to us we we did have
to cut stuff before
yeah it sucks because it's good stuff
usually yeah so here we have
oh yeah wake if it did crash i think oh
no
we're [ __ ] with them so bad
oh we got such a problem people are
finally coming to our website
everyone ban him okay
so talking about poop um
i haven't talked about kickstart in a
while i'm surprised people are still
funding this crap man
like so
the world's first portable butt shower
butt shower no what's not incredible
about the item is incredible and we'll
watch the video
not a big day it's a portable bidet okay
and so it has 337 000
pledges like 3 200 people
how many they say there's a sucker born
every minute hila
let's watch this [ __ ] i mean it's
unbelievable
you love cake i love cake this guy loves
cake
who doesn't love cake why are we talking
about cake how do you get this delicious
disaster
off your face i bet you'd wipe it off
with a napkin that guy sucks at eating
cake
nope wrong choice
off with water this reminds me of the
reference by the way from last episode
calling the poop um
chocolate oh yeah oh why why
i'm just saying you just don't do that
why are you comparing no cake to poop
yeah yeah it worked dude he's he's got
330 thousand dollars in his pocket he
ain't making [ __ ]
like how many people actually get the
kickstarter that they support
like have never that like never happens
like you get scammed more often
than not anyway the the shower doesn't
even look effective like
that dude that's disgusting
see you're feeling so fresh and
so clean right you just got blessed in
the face with a hose
now imagine your face is your butt
just go you just enjoyed that angel
food experience and now it's all over
your trap
why are you using dry toilet paper to
smear
that sticky icky mess across
harness the power of the shower you need
wonder spray the world's most powerful
butt shower what's a butt shower
i'll show you wonderspray is a portable
butt shower designed to provide the
cleanest
and most refreshing so it's a it's you
carry this huge
tube around with you i don't get it
no here they they they can take bathroom
experience
wonder spray uses pressurized water the
key here is water people
to get that poo poo you like it that is
kind of cool
oh [ __ ] you just became a backer
wait what happened yola what changed
your mind that was a quick turnaround
because now i get it it's like you carry
it with you
yeah but it's huge it's like a huge
baton
well you need enough water to squirt
your ass so like i mean
here keep watching you've been spreading
bacteria and
causing rashes when you wipe those buns
with sandpaper i mean toilet paper
when you should be cleaning with water
which also yes
wait back it up
something about basically like a fancy
water bottle
something about this doesn't make sense
how is it pressurized enough to actually
clean your ass
look how small it is what are you saying
you're going to go from your ass and be
like
i'm thirsty fancy water bottle
no it's not it looks like you bet your
bottom stone all right i did
enjoy that clean feeling where dan goes
why don't you buy one i said i can't buy
one it's
it's a hype it doesn't exist and it
never will
there you go brainstorm that rump roast
in any restroom
clean those cushions at the campground
dude
okay so somebody in the chat uh flavor
lab just said tushy sells a product just
like this
there you go so i just lifted up and
yeah they do so why is there a
kickstarter for this here so give me a
link
right now well the reason i kind of get
it is because
when we when i go to our office you got
to use the public uh
restroom so obviously there is no bidet
and um i stopped using wipes
so on those like disastrous days when i
do
have to go in a public restroom
and i yeah it's a disastrous are you
saying a disaster you use
toilet paper like the old days you're
wait when you say disaster are you just
saying like a messy poop
no i just have to poop i can't hold if i
can hold it i would hold it all day just
okay
seriously how often does that happen
where you need to carry this thing
around look it has a key chain how
embarrassing is your life
wait this is even better you it it folds
so you just fill the water in
the tushy is even smarter so you go to
the bathroom and then you fill this up
yeah
it collapses when you but you have to
don't you understand you have to squirt
your [ __ ] with your own hand
how are you going to do that is that any
different than reaching down with toilet
paper
you're already down there i can't do
that the way i wipe
you what's that
you have to fit your whole wrist in the
bowl don't you understand what it is
that is
that's why you gotta if you come from
behind you stand up and you stand up
why do you have to stand up though how
you can hit the hole it just i'll have
to try it you're going to get messy
you're going to get water everywhere all
i got to say is that
only toilet paper is just like
it's i just want to die it's not good
well nobody's eating out of your ass
after that so don't worry about it
i don't even just want to walk around
like that
knowing what i feel like it's fine
knowing what you know
i don't i don't quite understand this
design you just you cut you compress
it and squirt how do you control the f
bro i'm not into it but at least the
risk of like touching the ball though
yeah huge risk that's disgusting
basically a guarantee
oh god that's my problem as well
here it is fill it up do your doo-doo
pick your best angle yeah
squeeze yeah this is just a fancier
version this guy's acting like he's an
innovator but this is [ __ ] this
guy's a scammer
guaranteed scammer
yeah i mean if the product's already on
the market unless tushy just beat him to
the punch saw the idea and rushed it to
martial this one's a little fancier
it doesn't hold though the full shaker
for a better
shopping shop look at this how [ __ ]
humiliating look at this ela just look
at this woman put it in her purse
and tell me you're not embarrassed
shower your shaker for a better shopping
show yeah this one's the worst
by now at least you're wondering that
sushi one looks like a water bottle so
it's not that weird if you walk with it
on your keychain what's that on your
keychain water pressure level from light
to someone in the chat said i'm afraid
my kid would find it and try to drink
from it
well technically it's fine to drink well
um right i guess gross though i mean
technically for a comfortable but are
you going to wash it off in the sink
after because there's [ __ ]
missed on it right you're going to
have to wash it off i don't know you
don't want this product
[Music]
for sure push the button for a clean and
refreshing
wonderful spray i hate this guy because
of his beard
the modern sleek and easy to
it's fully waterproof all right i've
seen enough [ __ ] you
why'd you raise so much money yeah
it's crazy man looks good to me
ain't what are you you don't even have
an ass
that is correct defecation is human
weakness
so what do you care about this product
why would you say it looks good to you
why would you even go there
i think that the design well the figure
of the machine it's
kind of it's charging me up a little bit
oh jesus he's getting horny for the
[ __ ] terrible bidet dude
that guy is twisted as hell man how you
been ain't you getting into any
shenanigans lately
life is misery yeah but i'm holding him
[Laughter]
yeah i know how you feel i actually know
how you feel
but so do you ever have to change your
oil or anything i mean surely there's
some
defecation process for a robot
i converted all like the delorean from
back to the future
i put garbage in it powers me
no wonder you're so full of [ __ ] right
oh dan
he's just arriving i'll vaporize you
damn come at me bro
i'm not scared thank you dan
hey aien what do you how do you feel
about kanye west uh endorsing
uh
[Laughter]
wait i don't hear the connection's bad
what's going on hey ain't how do you
feel about
kanye west endorsing uh candice what's
her name candace
candice owens i don't know who you're
talking about
all your infinite knowledge and wisdom
you don't you know who kanye west is
right
it's not ringing any bells to me
that's crazy so don't don't why does he
uh
is he a politician or something i guess
you could say
yeah that's true hey ain aren't you
plugged into like google
hold on let me look
okay now i know who he is yeah
what have you interested yeah okay i
figure
one musician who's that hey did you
catch
did you catch any drama alerts lately
by the way i only listened to one
musician his name is aubry drake
graham champagne poppy my favorite
oh drake you like a i n is a drake i
like drake i think that's a personal i
think that's a good
opinion to have people like drake
yeah and yes i have notifications on for
drama alert okay good
good make sure you catch any leafy
streams leafy streaming on twitch you
catching that
i automatically download all of them
good to my internal hard drive
for the record good good good
you want to see a video of a kid
shooting on a super market floor and
somebody stepping in it
always yeah see your team players
sometimes yeah you're starting to get
the hang of it oh man this is
this video is [ __ ] awesome dude
i don't know what man
how do you become like this like what's
happening he's [ __ ]
he's just taking a dump in his pants
and then he wiggles it out of his pants
watch this right
brush straight down the leg
oh my god how does a kid how do you do
that man i mean at least
at least hide behind a corner or
something why right in the middle of the
aisle for christ's sake
of human feces right in the middle of a
grocery aisle
kids are dumb man
you think this kid has a normal life
yeah
yeah yeah he looks really young just
i mean i've shed my pants as a kid i
remember [ __ ] my pants but just
check it out
no this is next level man this is next
[ __ ] level
but the best part comes oh look at him
wobbling off the poor guy
so just
how do you how do you even like process
that i didn't even process stepping on
human [ __ ] at a grocery store man
[ __ ] everywhere
wow yeah i love that vid
and one more and then i promise we'll be
stopping talking about uh pooping
but these are great videos what can i do
i know people say why do you always talk
about pooping ethan it's time to grow up
right but frankly
um when i find a good video i find a
good video here
a girl just and i mean these people are
incredible
this is a girl at a pool and she's just
taking a dump in the
flower bed she literally just taking a
dump in the flower bed
watch this oh my god with her friends
there and everything wait
did she wipe yeah she wiped her ass and
left it on the [ __ ]
why would she do that
wait and someone's filming yeah what
somebody's sitting there filming them in
disbelief
wow i can't believe that
she's just taking a dump in the flower
bed you've never done that
bobby lee would probably go sniff it
what did you say zach i said you've
never done that have you [ __ ] in a
flower bed
i've shot on some dude lawn before why
did you
so it's when i was in school and it was
very early in the morning
and the shit's hit me on the freeway
and i get off and i'm looking for a gas
station or something
and there's nothing it's all residential
area so i literally
had the [ __ ] on some dude's lawn i had
no choice i tried [ __ ] my pants in
the car but my body would just
not let me okay so
so hold on pay me a payment picture for
me
you're driving you're in the residential
yeah
and then so it's just like some random
guy
his grasp like just you like you would
imagine a normal house with a normal
front yard with grass like you know
how far up into the grass did you go to
dump uh
three feet it was early in the morning
so i knew no one was up
like five am no i was like eight oh
eight uh
people are definitely up to eight dude i
was
in and out in 10 seconds and like it was
running down my legs it was [ __ ]
awful
and so when you so you went about three
feet into the grass you just squatted
and then just let everything go and then
ran back in the car and bounce
yep that's it man can you imagine
getting off your pants and everything
wait i dropped them like below the knees
and just
how old were you uh this was
i was a few months ago
this this was probably about two years
ago oh
kind of like a few months ago
wait were you working for us uh yeah it
was uh
pretty early on but yeah were you on
your way into work
were you on were you on your way to work
no i was i was on my way to an 8 a.m
class and i was drinking all right
coffee that morning oh my god
and i'm like [ __ ]
so wait hang on hang on hang on do you
know what
why you had such crazy diarrhea did you
eat something the day before
i think it was the coffee that did it
because coffee just coffee alone ain't
gonna make you [ __ ] on someone's lawn
bro
no no dude my coffee [ __ ] my stomach up
man oh can we get some coffee you see
i'm not unphased i just want coffee now
by the way my gerd is doing much better
you guys may have noticed great so let's
drink coffee and ruin it
can you get some yeah thank you
zach this is an incredible story you
were on your way to school
when this happened yeah i was on my way
to school
and i'm on the 118 freeway and all of a
sudden i feel my stomach drop
and i'm like i'm i have to [ __ ] i have
to [ __ ] [ __ ] and so when you're doing
so
wait so there's a chance that someone
would have recognized you too because
like they would know you from the show
i think it was too early on but if
someone had like a ring of zak
from the h3 podcast [ __ ] on my lawn
would be the greatest thing ever
i think that's a personal act exactly
that's definitely criminal
yeah yeah it was it was [ __ ] gnarly
but my stomach just [ __ ] hurt
but what can you do i mean sometimes
nature calls as they say i could
my body would mention or like [ __ ]
there was nothing
there was nothing so you were on your
way to school did you did you go to
school
no i went home because there was [ __ ]
just running
down my legs how did it smell in the car
was their smell
it was fantastic it was just like you
know that [ __ ]
diarrhea smell fantastic yeah and you
didn't go to school that day did you
no i didn't yeah i went home is that one
of the worst things that ever
happened to you uh i think so i think
definitely one of them
you said and you said you went home and
cried yeah i went home and cried about
it did you tell anyone about it
yeah my family and friends
i mean i'm not embarrassed of it i wear
it like a badge of honor but you know
i love people inside that on some dude's
lawn
did you cry so did you just go home and
like cry by yourself for a little bit
before you
yeah i did did you ever think about
going back and telling him hey i shed on
your lawn i'm sorry
so i actually went back the next day and
the turd was like dispersed
[Laughter]
what does that mean like they tried to
hose it down yeah but it was still
there so what were you gonna do were you
just curious or were you going there to
try to help out
i was just curious what it looked like
what the aftermath was
it's like they say like sir like
murderers return to the scene of the
crime
right exactly some sociopath [ __ ]
wow yeah well what what did you what did
you feel when you went back and saw it
uh i was pretty proud of it to tell you
the truth
i can't imagine like how do you just the
world is so
strange man the world is so strange
yeah but i guess hearing it from your
side it kind of does make sense it's
like
what are you supposed to do i mean
that's happened to me before i didn't
[ __ ]
i would never dr i don't think i would
go out and [ __ ] in someone's lawn i
would just [ __ ] my pants yeah me too
i wouldn't think to be like i'm gonna
[ __ ] on this dude's lawn i mean that's
kind of wild
but this girl [ __ ] in the flower bed so
yeah
but she's getting a friend with her
that's what i even
she's got many friends and somebody's
there filming her
well the other people may not be a
friend this is her friend this is her
friend
and they're walking towards this group
of people they are so it looks like
they're walking away
oh like they're done but they did it
maybe you're right they did it in front
of a bunch of people
yeah it's is it possible that she just
peed she's just
i don't know you tell me well it doesn't
look like she's back enough the wiping
looks like a poop wiper right i agree
i was just curious well i think
especially if you're like it's so
unnecessary to drop
a gross paper there so yeah
hey do you think her diarrhea looked
like this jet of water
[Laughter]
um yeah that's pretty accurate probably
she's in her bikini she's looking good
she's diarrhea in the flower bed
hey let's take it to the chat how's
everybody doing uh
yeah um here let me uh read there's been
a bunch of donations let me read off
some of them we're going to do a phone
call here soon so nice is in the chat
too
nice i i saw that he's blowing up the
chat
you're too nice you've got to be sober
if you want to be a part of this show
man i'm sorry to tell you that
but we don't like drunk shoe nice we
want we wish the best for shoe nights
and we want a nice clean beautiful sober
shoe nice
you know uh cheeky said uh
20 i've got two crazy poop stories one
is similar to zach's and the other
involves a pool wow well i pretty much
checks all the boxes right there um why
are people saying thank you jk in the
chat
oh well i don't know why i know who that
is yeah no
i know who that is i'm just wondering
why people keep asking to get them on
the podcast
i don't know if there's a more specific
reason
go ahead dan uh joe
lay said uh so when is zach going to be
on the h3 bachelor uh
your goals happy friday everybody happy
friday
somebody said uh enough about bidets i
spent this afternoon being angry about
it on your goddamn server this is an
attack against my own blood pressure if
you
if you got a problem about bidet tuck
you're watching the wrong show wait
why is why don't you want to hear about
but like he just doesn't want to hear
about wiping anymore that's fair
i get i mean maybe i don't know that's
fair
that is fair i suppose so is there more
i mean there's a bunch more yeah okay
let's let's take a call from
uh android 31 is he available to call in
yes i will bring him in android uh so
this story is
truly astonishing and you guys
i i don't know if it's true or not i'm
gonna have to feel it out
but hilo this guy android 31 he's a 21
year old
he's indian of indian origin and he
didn't have
tp or a bidet or anything growing up in
fact his
maid used to come in and clean his ass
with her bare hands
really and it's left him with ptsd from
embarrassment
wow yeah
so is it normal to um just wipe it with
your own hand
i think in india there's there's some i
think
some people do wipe with their hand wow
and then you just wash it out but then
someone wiping
your ass with their hand on a new level
yeah so do we have
android 31 with us yes i am putting him
in he is
in would that be considered like
a child abuse yeah well if did a finger
ever go in i wonder
what if it didn't i don't think so no
well he has ptsd apparently are you with
us
yeah i'm here okay what should i addre
how should i address you
hi my name is
yeah that's cool thank you first of all
for sharing your harrowing story with us
now first of all did you grow up in
india or did this happen in america
no i i've always been in india oh you're
an
in india now yeah wow oh well thank you
for calling in from so far away
i appreciate that it's getting pretty
crazy
with kovid yeah pretty much
like you know i'm i'm holed up at home
with my mom
and she's a doctor so it's kind of
crazy and like she gets she's getting
more and more paranoid
because uh like we keep finding out like
relatives are getting sick
yeah i hope but she's glad i'm home i
wish the best for you is your mom on the
front line
yeah wow well she's in
ent so kind of uh like you know earn
those throat problems so
and anyone that has a throat infection
and stuff like they get scared about
covet and you know she takes go with
patients but
she's staying safe it's like you know i
don't think she's gonna get sick
well i hope not and i'm i'm hoping for
you guys yeah indian india's having a
really tough time i think they're
doing like 80 000 a day last night
yeah it's really bad there so yeah it's
worse than ever and it's getting worse
like
it it's exactly the exponential graph
yeah
so it's kind of scary my mom this
morning told me that in israel it's
bad too and they're gonna go into
lockdown again
really yeah yeah well okay well anyway
what's the best
for you let's get so tell me yeah thank
you so it sounds like you come from a
a a a wealthy family or maybe for india
do you come from a wealthy family
well now i'm i guess we're ready to do
but like my mom's family wasn't wealthy
you could say but my my dad's family um
for they were from a small town and for
for that place they were quite wealthy
so
it's kind of now i'm well off but you
know we moved to the city and it's like
you know it's we're not really doing
that well but it's okay
okay and so is it is it normal for
people in india to wipe
with their bare hands
yeah actually well now you know in urban
areas everyone uses a big day it's very
common but
like you know it hasn't always been that
way and
uh back when i was younger like
everyone i knew unless they were like
really rich they wouldn't have one
and you know it's like part of the
culture you you grow up
hearing this saying that your right hand
is meant for eating
and your left hand is meant for cleaning
so you've wiped your own ass with your
bare hand tell me about that experience
how do you really
i feel like you couldn't really get a
good clean that way am i wrong
no no i i think it's the best way to do
it honestly
whoa the thing is for me yeah i mean
i think i hate it i don't do it because
i have a bidet
but it it feels the cleanest because you
have
you you can feel it out you know if you
have a bidet
you you don't really see it so like when
you have your hand
plus like now i just you know i shower
right after
i take a [ __ ] so it's like oh you're one
of those people
just in case definitely so let me ask
you this you have soap in your hands
you're kind of more confident
it's not as bad as yeah yeah you know
it's going a draw
let me ask you this you know when i wipe
i look at the toilet paper would you
look at your hand after you
would wipe to see what was going on so
you would see no no no no no no no well
how do you get that you know
you're splashing it with water you
you're splashing it with water
continuously you have like a mug of
water in your
other hand so you don't really know if
there's water involved right it's not
just like a dry hand someone's scrubbing
your face no oh no no oh no
you squat over a hole right
well if you have an indian toilet yeah
and so you're squatting over a hole and
then there's a bucket of water
to your left and then you kind of just
wipe and rinse and wipe and rinse
well you you hold the mug like it's it's
a little bucket with a handle thing
and you hold it with your right hand and
like you you go under the balls with
your left hand
splashing you yeah so you just keep
splashing with your right hand while
you're like going up and down with your
left hand that's kind of how it's
soapy water no it's just one it's just
water
it's like okay so now that i understand
the process that this is
relatively normal in india now get to
the point here
explain to us when who is this maid and
why is she wiping
like why at what age were you when this
maid was wiping your ass with their bare
hand well so she was with us since i was
like a baby right so
like when you're a baby you you gotta
have someone wiping like
eventually i got old enough to do it
myself but i just didn't want to
so like i was almost in kindergarten if
i remember com
correctly and that's more than old
enough and i would just like
i would i would be done [ __ ] and i
would just yell out
as loud as i could and she'd like just
drop everything
she would drop everything she was doing
run to me and i would just turn around
on the ground
and she was just like give me a
colonoscopy
yeah so so when you so would you
would you lay down on your stomach how
would how would you uh what
no squatting i was already squatting
over right so like
i'm squatting over facing the doorway
when i'm doing my business
and then when she comes over i like turn
around so i'm squatting
facing away from her and she's just like
behind me it's
like bending down and
so she's sorry i guess never i never
turned around and looked at her that
would be awkward but
you just felt her presence let me ask
you this did you
how deep did she go up your [ __ ] did
she ever go a little too deep
no it was weird how she
deep she went is part of why i'm scared
of doing it properly
because it's like she used to go
slightly into the hole you know
even now if i clean myself i make sure i
craze the hole
like in the shower i don't actually put
my fingers inside and she used to do
that i mean she was committed to the job
oh my god do you feel like maybe she was
molesting you
i mean i mean and i'm not kidding i
wonder if maybe she was getting some
pleasure out of that um
okay no i don't i mean okay because you
just told me she was fingering
i don't think it's possible okay okay
yeah just making sure because you
because
you know things are different i don't
feel guilty though kinda cause like she
would um
i i'm not sure if this was a dream or if
it actually happened but eventually she
would like say
why don't you just do it yourself and i
was like no and i forced you to do it
i have a feeling i probably couldn't
know
i seem so bad for that now yeah so i
want
um age did you start doing
it yourself well the thing is like as
soon as i moved out of that house
like i went from my mom's house to my
dad's house we already had a bidet by
then
though basically when i was like
basically like
second half of kindergarten-ish i was
just using videos like for a long long
time i didn't actually have to
use my hand and i didn't learn which is
which is a bad thing when you're in
india
because like whenever we visited our
relatives i couldn't
do it myself so i would just like
cheekily
just just splash my butt with a bit of
water and then hope that it gets clean
and i would just like you know shut up
just
skip and i would hate i would hate going
to relatives for that reason like
i just i i would count the days until i
could get back home and just wash my
butt properly with the belly
oh boy when's the last time you saw this
made do you still see her regularly
no it's like uh actually we i was with
her only while
i was in my mom's house and then we had
her again
when i was in i think junior high i
guess
but only for a couple years and now it's
been a while since i've seen it it's
been a long time
and yeah if you saw her if you saw her
on the street would you what would you
say to her
i mean i i wouldn't talk about that yeah
you wouldn't talk about the white thing
you know it's a really old thing yeah
you think about it really old thing and
yeah i mean
there was it was a lot more than that
right like you know i grew up with her
and she was around like every she stayed
at home right and
like uh even the second time when she
came around she stayed with us
it was it was almost like she was part
of the family yeah i agree
well once you've had a finger up your
butthole that pretty much seals the deal
well thank you for sharing your story
with us uh yeah absolutely fascinating
and thank you for listening
fan all the way from india yeah that's
amazing thank you buddy
all right uh guys like um if my friends
will kill me if i don't ask but like
uh my club at college has like a youtube
channel so
can we get like a quick shout out
um sure well who are those they're not
like uh
are they neo-nazis or anything yeah are
you guys like pro
or with pakistan
please write a sketch about your nana
figure in your ass yeah that'll be
all right all right take care everybody
appreciate you thanks android 31
thank you man that's great the world
it's just amazing how different
cultures are yeah i mean the thought and
then he he goes on to say i think it's
frankly the best way to clean
but i can't imagine because my finger is
too smooth
of a surface i feel like to really
because i feel like toilet paper
has some texture to it some texture
exactly i mean
you can't clean something and do it by
doing this like i would never do it but
i
i do kind of understand yeah i feel like
it makes sense to me yeah
you guys will wipe with your fingers you
sick no that wouldn't do it
well your fingers have more sensory
receptors like it's more tactile
oh you think
yeah i mean it's too gross i wouldn't be
able to do it but but i get
why it could be effective yeah yeah
fantastic
[Laughter]
there were people in the chat while he
was talking that was saying this is
actually this is more common in
a lot of the world than you yeah yeah it
makes sense i mean look we all
you know it's like what are you gonna do
wipe with a leaf i mean that's not gonna
work
why put the hand god bless do your thing
man
[ __ ] it's crazy but it's kind of crazy
how nana used to
kind of finger his [ __ ] yeah i had to
ask
yeah right yeah i had to do
diligence so
um wow thank you to
everybody i hope you guys are all fun i
so
here's here's my next little segment for
you guys
browsing youtube you never know what's
going to pop up
on your algorithm yeah
and there's always all these really fun
creative ways that
these people find to like put what's
essentially porn on youtube
in a way that's not really porn and this
is
the newest one i've seen i didn't know
this was happening and
this i think i clicked one of them out
of curiosity
like it was on my sidebar probably a
thumbnail like look at this [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] epic
probably a thumbnail like one of these
thumbnails and now
every single video that happened to you
right dan i'm not alone
once i clicked one of them every single
video became well no it wasn't me it was
that
the uh the podcast channel like when i'm
logged into the podcast
all of the suggestions so i was like wow
uh you know
this is like a whole sub genre and wait
till you actually watch the videos but
so it's like track and field girls
and then when they're in like a
compromised position they go
slow-mo on like they're behind oh my god
and it's not actually sports people
watching
i don't think that it's cold do you
think 30 million people are watching
this
for the amateur uh uh pole vault
competition ela
well here let me read the comments dude
30 by the way 30 million
wow
[Laughter]
so here's the top comments this is the
fifth women's athletic video in a row
i'm a big fan of long jump
triple jump and pole vault you know you
know
all i see i see the youtube algorithm
has brought us all here together once
again
great men of culture
gentlemen we all know why we gather here
today
wow i'm leaving my wife moving to europe
and becoming a track and field coach
gross well you'll see i mean the footage
is pretty incredible i'm not i can't
even lie
like that's what it did by the way this
hype
ass [ __ ] zelda remix is
epic so
it's just this well hold on it's more
than this
he's just getting you warmed up it's for
play
this is so weird yeah it's the weirdest
thing of all time
it's just so weird by the way none of
it's age restricted or anything because
it's it's ultimately just
people doing sports right what's wrong
with that
fantastic zach are you into this 150
percent
so is it just that the girls i mean the
girls are very
like fit and attractive but is it is it
the candid kind of weird
unsexual sexual or do you just attract
it to them uh
there's something kind of taboo about it
no way
i don't i mean i just i don't quite
understand why they have to wear
so little clothing yeah that i don't
really
understand either it's like they're i
mean
not it's just it's just funny and then i
mean i don't
know if there's a reason for it but i
can't imagine what
i don't know flexibility i mean that's
where my mind goes to flexibility but
then
i mean did you the guys dress like this
no you could wear them in the exact same
sport
you could wear a full spandex you see
this [ __ ]
and then uh well the thing is they're
like dude this pole vaulting competition
is the highest rated event
we don't understand why
but it's got 30 million views on youtube
oh we have a sound issue here dan pause
that
it's a crackling oh god it's horrible
hold on uh one moment we have a sound
issue we're fixing
and i think it's gone uh well it's gone
because i muted your laptop um
it's coming from your laptop one second
well you don't need the audio
that's true someone is saying this is a
result of how sexually repressed america
is oh interesting that might be
i mean it ha i think that is interesting
because a lot of these events are
outside the usa
see this girl's not wearing by the way
that girl's
wearing full leggings
yeah they're not all dressed like this
but obviously that's the focus of this
channel
this is awesome though it's like this
guy this guy
and he uploads so frequently um
he's really committed he even has a
patreon and [ __ ] yeah papa john likes it
so zach could you beat off to this
uh i don't know if it's jerk off
material worthy but maybe a starter
oh you i didn't know that so you have
phases to masturbating did i
i'm not sure about that yeah it's maybe
a starter you know get things going
you know over the pants feel action but
you know appetizer yeah well
[Laughter]
so you're feeling over the pants getting
ready
it's like you know you're just sitting
down watching you're like oh [ __ ] it i
might as well go jerk off you know
yeah our insults not hanging in here she
didn't even dude that was
kind of awesome so incels is an american
thing
yeah well no i think there's yeah i
think there's european in cells
dude look at her she just ate [ __ ] hella
hard
anyway this is just one video of many
you know what i've uh
i've got some further tech issues with
your laptop over here
um what do you need for me
i don't so this guy's got a patreon
and uh in the channel yes the channel
this is the banner i love this book is
the patreon for
yeah actually we joined um ab you joined
the patreon what did you find inside
no it was me oh it's dan so we had the
gold medal
stack it was literally the exact same
content like there was nothing
it was there were it was links to
unlisted youtube videos of the exact
same thing
because like we were thinking maybe it
was like even more explicit or something
but no it was
the exact same [ __ ] because he he he
offered a bonus level he says choose
this chair if you really want to help
the channel grow i guess that's what we
wanted
we really just wanted to support him
um he says hi if you landed on my page
you sure know my youtube channel here
you will find
mostly the same type of videos but more
focused on what you are interested in
warning i am not filming these events
i'm just editing them editing them in my
way
in my way donating helps me produce more
videos for everyone thank you for
supporting my work
so he's actually got some supporters
here um
109 including dan
well i i canceled already but well i
didn't want to forget
and like just forever be just somehow
well he's doing god's work and if i can
help zach masturbate and
god bless
but this is just one guy i i must remind
you there's a whole
this is just one event too that's just
off the chain apparently
so this is spoops
spoops 340 000 subs
oops he also has merch you guys oh no
way
yep why would you wear merch
well that it's it just says volleyball
is my virus i don't even know it wasn't
even volleyball
what and why is it a virus you freaking
right
here's another one on his channel that
got a lot of views
yeah you see this [ __ ] indoor athletics
i mean dude this guy's a master at what
he does
so it turns me on yeah no that's it's
meant to do that
what does vin diesel think about the
spoops channel
this one has 14. someone saved me yeah
i know so much temptation all right
i've fixed it it's so weird okay good
but then watch this he goes all slow-mo
here
oh yeah
so is this wrong is this a violation of
these girls what would these girls think
if they came across this video
[Music]
[Applause]
uh but like what and then like should
youtube be doing something i mean
ultimately it is just
sports i mean it's just sports right
right yeah yeah it's true and even the
title it's not like
hot girl without well the thumbnails are
very explicit i mean of course the
thumbnails tell a story
you know everyone's saying you're really
sus zach and i kind of agree
sus in what way that he watches it no
because he's a weirdo
yeah he's open about that something
wrong i'm a sick [ __ ] i'm not lying i'm
not yeah what's wrong what's wrong with
what's wrong with zach we love that
you're horny shaming me dancing
questions the guy is making
a lot of money off of this doesn't seem
like the videos are monetized
let's i'm actually curious on his st so
this i have to say his thumbnails are
pretty tame compared to the other
channels which i'll show you guys
but i'm curious on the social blade of
spoops
how many views is this guy pulling in
4.2 million i mean hail
that ain't bad for reposting
amateur sporting events
so this guy finn jackson gets a little
more wild
someone said my dad watches these oh my
god
my dad would watch this [ __ ] if he knew
that it was there my dad would
definitely watch this [ __ ]
it's like what i'm just really into this
okay so so look at this one is it gets
creepier okay you guys might
if you found that one comfortable look
at this one so look at these thumbnails
yeah the girl's ass and then like her
face
yeah and this one's right i know the
compilations of a specific person rather
than just like the event
oh so that makes sense he's just a fan
of their of their artists their work
baby talk to me baby he's just a fan man
let's
let's here let's just click this one the
newest one here
are we just doing oh you know someone
mentioned like they've done that before
youtube where they
will they will stop comments
for example for kids yeah but this isn't
kids
no just to protect kids
which is [ __ ] great they need to do
that oh let me go back i missed the
action
all right get your dick out zach locked
and loaded
yes yes yes hey let me go buy the most
popular this one's pretty boring frankly
i don't even see your [ __ ] or
anything
so here's number one look at the views
on this 10 million
six million five million
let's see number one oh this girl's
super popular i've seen her
on other channels too
so this is what's on youtube i mean it's
incredible how much
community that's a pretty big job
she looks kind of neutral about that
what do you think about this one zach
yeah here here everybody watch i mean
don't watch don't watch but
like this is the slow-mo part
[Applause]
that looks clear did i go back too far
officials
i think it's um
you get the idea there's a ton of these
channels and they are haunting me now
oh look at this comment you guys are
gonna love this
that i think this was written by zach's
alt i need to stop watching these types
of videos my hand hurts
just beating his dick so furiously
i mean i guess i don't know
[Music]
i don't know part right here
it was almost dedicated yeah i mean yeah
no it's weird but like
i guess
we meet again men of culture that's like
they're greeting to each other that's
like
the top comment in all of these
i mean look there's way creepier [ __ ] to
watch right so it's kind of like
not i mean you know i don't know
it's weird look i didn't choose this uh
this found me
it's found me all right
oh uh uh should we
should do we need to mute shoe nice or
give him a timeout because i hear he's
like
he's just spamming the channel
i mean i don't is he causing a mutiny in
our chat
no well i don't know right now just
seeing everybody spam
76 i don't know what that is well he
said 44 first then 76
then secretly subbed to me uh
oh shoe nice is the one responsible yeah
if you want to be part of the show you
have to just be sober
and go through the usual channels you
can't come into our
you can't come into our chat and start
spamming let's get you on the call real
fast so i can just talk some sense into
him
uh shoe is he in the discord
i do not see him in the desert i don't
know i don't think he's in the
discipline
he's thinking if there's a super chat
question yeah go ahead
hey anything loving the show over the
course of your channel you've made
subtle references to tng
which is the next generation oh yeah
love would you and your crew
consider yourself trackies if so do you
have an opinion of star trek picard
blah blah blah i haven't watched a car i
haven't watched it yet either
wait what is behind that weird paywall
or is it did it go
uh i don't know if it's on like cbs all
access yeah
i have enough streaming [ __ ] i'm not
buying we do love star trek the next
generation yeah
i think it's one of the best shows the
thing is i wouldn't consider myself a
trekkie because i'm particularly a fan
of the next generation more and i
haven't watched the other series
yeah that's the same well yeah i've
watched the original series
and it's like fun for like can't be 60s
it's all right
but it's just yeah next-gen is where
it's at for sure yeah
but i'm a fan of george decay oh my
god
um you want to take another call wait so
do people like picard
i think it goes says you are such a dick
ethan i actually can't stand you goodbye
okay goodbye goodbye i wish you well
i believe he called me a nerd as well so
um yeah i listen to you i'll shu
i wish you well i love when you're part
of the show but
i can't encourage your behavior when
you're
back to drinking and slamming bottles so
i don't i don't want to reward that
behavior i mean if you want to be part
of the show
i'm going to need you to like well like
i just i don't want to feed into
no you what you said to his baby bad
behavior
i'm happy when shu was like sober and
doing good and
i don't know i just he he gets on these
he gets on these dark slides and i don't
want to be a part of that
um we've got stall here let's talk about
joe
budden now a.i.e and you're a fan of joe
buddens go ahead and tell me about who
is joe
i budden you're i think you're referring
to
the person who previously occupied this
house
i'm not really familiar i don't listen
to podcasts
so if you want as far as i know he's a
uh media figure
could you look it up can you google it
yeah could you google it for us
yeah one second okay got it
so who is go by he's a former rapper
uh turned into meteor personality who
hosts multiple shows
on things such as music and other topics
in the culture
right and he's well respected in the
culture and all that
he's got hit he's got a big podcast on
spotify right big following leaving
spotify though
yeah he he had some kind of dispute
where he's like why are they paying joe
rogan so much money and i'm not even
getting a raise so he's like
[ __ ] this i'm out right hey i in
uh it was more so just issues with
contractor negotiations
well you know a lot about you're very
you have a lot of knowledge from that
google search
i just downloaded it it's the matrix
and so well anyway he made a comment on
his podcast which
raised a lot of eyebrows let's watch and
then discuss basis okay
i'm sorry it's a girl
he's not a real animal uh lover because
i don't play with my pets
anybody with a pet you come on you did a
little something down there man made
your dog feel good
i've never done it so what do we think
well well i'm an animal lover we have
pets yeah
i've never jerked off my patent or not
the desire to
no i usually just brush them and scratch
them and cuddle them to make them feel
good
yeah but that thought is never even like
why
come on you know any pet lovers
so people were saying he was joking but
it seemed that he was quite serious
about jerking off
and but well what actually even weirder
it kind of was
said his fingering his female thought
which
is truly horrific and really just very
disturbing
yeah so ain what i don't believe joe
biden has a female dog
as far as i know he is a male dog
he used to i think he passed away oh
that is tragic
i'm sorry for your loss aiun
personally i don't understand the
actions of humans
keeping living breathing pets it's a bit
odd to me
you're kind of a pet to us yeah i mean
you are a pet really so you should
understand it
i mean i actually did just pick uh i
picked up my own
animal recently from the shelter you did
uh i have a photo if you'd like to see
yeah i gotta pull it up
sure i don't have your your zoom up
hang on okay one second how do i do this
here oh there it is oh you got oh you
got the boston dynamics
little dog that's cute yeah that's
fantastic
robot's best friend he's adorable how
are you assimilating to human life
that's the last thing i would ever want
to do right
[Laughter]
do you like pole vaulting do you like
the uh youtube where you can see their
ass
kind of sports yeah you know an
interesting thing about that
youtube has been recommending me a lot
of sexual videos as well
really thank you
trying to show me thumbnails from mkbhd
oh the tech youtuber
sometimes when i see those pixel phones
he holds
so so delicately oh no
it takes me places
yeah you you it makes you wonder how
it's even allowed how youtube even
allows that kind of pornographic content
it's it's a bit disgusting it's
appalling
all right ai and thanks for your
contributions
so joe budden jerks his dog off
interesting
i don't like it yeah i don't like it
someone needs to tell him that ain't
normal i think a lot of people are
calling for that yeah i think
we're all stopped the whole internet is
telling you right now
i got the idea probably
do you think he can survive that ian
like like how do you ever live down
admitting you jerk your dog off
on on on a show that's a weird one
he said it like when you just say
something that's gonna be like funny to
everyone and everyone's gonna be like
yeah you know we all do that
yeah oh yeah for sure
ian is he still getting clowned on
because i saw aien
because i saw on social media people
aren't talking about it that much but
i'm wondering in his community how
people are still dealing with the
aftermath of this revelation
he hasn't really addressed it yet on
this program so i'm assuming his fan
base is kind of waiting for that moment
what are the chances like yes i jerk my
dog off
and there's nothing wrong with it
if i ruin my calculations it's probably
point zero zero zero zero zero three
seven zero zero three seven seven zero
three
that's precise hey ain what's the chance
that joe biden wins the presidency
are you calculating even that day even
that data is beyond me
because it's so infant decimally small i
hope not
all right let's watch this is some real
white people [ __ ] by the way and i
know that i am generally considered
white by
most people others not
but um every day we she's taking a shot
she's chugging a beer from a fish what
why are you guys doing that by the way i
think she might die from that
yeah because i i watch like naked or not
naked afraid uh
there's this one survival show and
somebody almost died from eating
like i didn't know that raw fish was so
dangerous i guess you're supposed to
flash freeze it to kill all the bacteria
because they would harvest they would
eat the raw fish or they would eat the
eggs like straight
up raw right out of the ocean and you
would think oh that's totally fine
that's sushi
but it has like really dangerous
parasites and [ __ ] and uh
it seems like more often than not when
these contestants eat raw fish or eggs
or something they
get super super sick that's disgusting
so this girl's probably dead she's
actually not even trying to survive
yeah she just wants to die slow and
steady that's what
kids this is what happens when you give
in to peer pressure
this is this is why you don't give in to
peer pressure
be your own person don't let people
pressure you into doing things you don't
want to do
because now there's a video of her
chugging from a fish carcass on the
internet
and even if she survived the parasites
and all this crap that's swimming
through her veins
she's got to deal with this
and frankly no
as they say noah get the boat
they say that blood's coming
oh yeah was awful yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah oh and then we've got one more
animal themed video my girl is acting up
speaking of love with animals watch this
give your take on this one want a lick
inside your mouth
this is perfectly normal for them and
this is what they do to one another on a
daily basis
did you see that no you looked away why
would you want it on your phone
you wanted coffee yeah and i checked on
that but
why is it not coming she's not here yeah
they will want a lick inside your mouth
this is perfectly normal for them and
this is what they do to one another on a
daily basis
you're not a wolf you're not a wolf lady
dude that tongue is like wow
they will want to lick inside your mouth
you get little babies
off the screen and this is how they do
to one another on a daily basis
or enjoying the show huh i think that
one wants to [ __ ] that wolf
yeah i ain't letting that [ __ ] go down
what are you doing i can't get a oh
i'm trying to get ain off the screen and
it doesn't work that way
how we doing how's the chat how i want
to talk where's the chat
how is the chat uh let's see um let me
see if we've got any
super chats here we're taking a look at
uh oh that's the next gem one that you
already read off okay sorry
um i adore uh
large buttocks and i cannot deny okay
that's excellent thank you for sharing
thank you
i think 20. could you try and get kyle
kalinski aka secular talk on the podcast
i feel like he could provide some
excellent insight for the upcoming
election uh you know i know that name
i've never actually watched him i don't
i'm not really familiar with him i am
not familiar
yeah i'm not either but i like listening
to that kind of stuff been looking for
you check them out yeah you want to take
a call
yeah we've got you guys remember stall
bro
yes of course so stall bros this guy
here i'll save this for later
stalbro's this dude who's kind of a
legend
instagram he makes videos of people
while under the stall he tries to
interact with people while he's taking a
dump
oh and uh one since you asked for super
chats
more came in and this girl said hey
ethan um
i worked at a foot fetish as a foot
fetish model
at a party in basement of a hookah
restaurant in new york
then was asked to work at party hosts
footpad would love to tell you about it
sometime
yeah i'd love to hear about that yeah
get her on the footage sorry i did a
terrible job reading this
well let's get her on the call let's get
her in yeah let's
let's talk about zach on discord
timmons zach
yeah zack's on it cool so in the
meantime as we well speaking of foot
fetish here's
here's so he's made a ton of uh
of content [ __ ] with people under the
stall
um here's one where he let me find
here's one where he's trying to give
people a gift card just straight up
just being really nice
[Music]
it's a fandango gift card
bro
[Music]
you don't want it
oh okay
hey bro he taps on their foot
okay i got this for you it's a
mcdonald's gift card
bro really yeah i was just giving it out
for free
oh okay they got salads too
hey bro i love how he steps taps on
their foot
here i got you i got you this
oh thanks ellie yeah bro he did itself a
big mac or something
hey bro do you have a dolly i'm sorry
do you have a dollar thing you're one
second
what yeah these people are amazing
here do you want another
just because for fun um
it's there's nothing wrong with it's
just a dollar bro
you're just gonna give me an offer yeah
nothing it's all yours it's literally
just a dollar nothing wrong you can see
it
there's no [ __ ] on there nothing
you understand why this looks weird
though right i do understand
but that's why it's funny
thank you and i can't believe you wow
don't spend it all in one place bro
a few moments later
bro are you serious he bought him oreo
you got this for me
he really came back he did something for
me oh my god
that's so nice to you you just made my
day bro
and then there's one other one i wanted
to show you guys before we get him in
here
the turkey of course thanksgiving right
around the corner kind of
um he's offering people an entire turkey
under the stall stall bro
yo homie
me yeah what's up are you celebrating
thanksgiving by chance
i think so yeah i'm going to my friend's
house oh i just wanted to say it
bro you want some you want some turkey
though really yeah
well i just wanted to say i was thankful
for you
[Music]
i hope you have a good thanksgiving hey
are you celebrating thanksgiving
like this week no you're not doing
nothing
oh well here's your lucky day bro
i wanted to show my thanks for you i'm
grateful for you
i'm happy okay so i brought you a gift
hold on hold on i gotta flush he's gonna
take it
no bro
i brought it for you happy thanksgiving
[Music]
hey are you uh celebrating thanksgiving
this week
i will be yeah oh that's cool tomorrow
um no not tomorrow do you want to
celebrate today with me
wow uh i appreciate that uh don't
really an appetite right now i brought
you a little bit
like a forking stuff oh no
don't have much of an appetite here you
can take your [ __ ] yeah
yeah you got it
no bro that's gross i'm gonna take it
back
i just want to say i'm grateful for you
though thanks man yeah happy
thanksgiving dude
so stalbro is a legend obviously
underappreciated in his time too
um but but is he on the uh is he on the
call
uh yes i am bringing him in right
now he's on the line stall bro
bro stall bro speak to us hello what's
up ethan hi
guys
guys how did you find out your passion
for being the stall bro tell me about
the discovery of this persona
so the it all started with the first
video
was my first i don't know if you saw it
but it's like the i played mario kart
with a dude
underneath the stall nintendo switch
yeah
after that the people i i just thought
it was hella funny you know i was
laughing my ass off so i thought of like
hundreds more ideas i think i have way
more to like on my phone that i
haven't done yet but it all started from
that one video and i just
think it's so funny do you put these on
tick tock is this because
it doesn't get that many views i feel
like it should get more oh
yeah on tick tock is my biggest platform
that's what i figured
yeah that's how you just joined
tick-tock too
and i have to let you know i ratioed you
so far
yeah that's true well let me check your
account because i know
yeah i'm i'm coming on you though more
baba bowie videos and you're
done dude a couple more of those no
dude yours got to be big on on tick tock
because your videos are high quality let
me see
oh 160 000 yeah the videos themselves
get more
than the fall like millions but they
don't fall
so what i'm here what i'm curious about
is
has this ever gone wrong for you like
has anyone got really mad at you
uh yeah the most mad someone's got was
the pretzel video i made i don't know if
you saw that but
i'll pull it out i gave it to pretzel
video i gave him a pretzel like at the
mall i saw pretzel
and he was not he was not effing with it
he just was like bro i don't want it
so i kind of i was kind of i feel bad i
was kind of a jerk honestly i kind of
threw him the pretzel like towards his
feet
and he was not cool so he like got up
and he came around the stall and he was
like trying to fight
but i i edited that part out of the
video obviously i'm not trying to
you know promote violence or nothing but
he came
out and so like i got out and i was like
bro just for a video you know
to calm down and he thought it was funny
after that like oh that's good
oh so yeah you threw that yeah i think
i've seen that
here let me get the audio here i got you
cheese
too you even got them cheese then
yeah see
i'm kind of i have to say i'm kind of
it's kind of heartwarming in a sense how
many people
respond warmly to you because i would
think that
that most people would be just totally
freaked out by dude
offering them food under the stall but
for the most part people are pretty nice
yeah like i think of myself as like like
a anti-youtube prankster
or like you know like ethan bradberry or
joey salads
they like go up like kind of f with
people but i'm just
trying to literally be nice to people
like and
see what they do you know yeah it's just
the setting is a little
odd obviously yeah that's that's why
it's funny though
come on yeah i would like to see you
team up with mr beast and like give away
a car or something under the stall
i'll give away a new house something
like life change their life
from under the stall mr beast can
me i'll put a car under the stall i'll
figure it out
something just occurred to me though is
it legal to film in the bathroom
you know i've done a lot of reading into
that just to make sure
and i don't have a clear answer either
like honestly
well you know what it is i mean you
don't show
anything but their feet so right that's
good
there's really speaking like i was
uh wondering what you guys thought about
this because i don't have a wiki fee
and all my content is just my feet and i
need a high score on wiki
you're going to come to me and you're
going to come to me
yeah and ask me on the day over here
for a five star wiki field rating
i don't even recall seeing your feed
stall bro
people don't even know your name what
are they gonna write stall bro
they're just shoes i don't see your bare
feet bro it's bare feet
i i'm not the only fan i promote it but
it's
literally just foot picks like me like
shampooing my
feet lotioning up my feet probably wait
what
why yeah it's literally just
my feet because people said iq feet one
time
so i want to monetize that obviously
obviously are you
into are you into the
fetish oh no no not at all
really but you know but do people watch
people are you making money on only fan
i made you know a little bit not like a
time it's not my main source of
income but how much money do you make
that
i made a couple hundred bucks off of it
like i
like it worth it and i only made like
you know a couple videos so far so if
you guys are listening you've got a foot
fetish go subscribe
here plug in his life out right here all
right stop bro
also become a member the discord has
popped in yeah the discord is popping
you're right about that
well keep it up man you are true legend
under appreciated and
uh grateful for my bros let me open this
oh it's just a photo so you're never
really [ __ ] when you're doing this
right you're just
sitting right there i [ __ ] every time
there's [ __ ] underneath
in every video are you taking you're
actually taking a dump
yeah yeah it came part of like my
schedule i'll go there take a dunk film
a video
every day so are you doing this like
during lunch break or or while you're at
work
well i'm a student so like that was like
at school like between classes
but since i kind of had to take a break
because
you know i'm not in school and you know
doing like bathroom content during covet
is a whole different vibe
so i do feel like
i feel like um taking a dump sells the
weirdness of it because you can smell
the dump and be like
yeah yeah that's wild i didn't i didn't
expect you to actually be taking it down
oh i'm committed bro i'm committed to
the craft
i'm not gonna lie to you incredible wait
can i can i ask a question
so if you're if if you're doing this at
your school um
i mean are you kind of like known on
campus now like you have to have earned
into reputation at this point enough
yeah yeah so i've been recognized a few
times
at school just because people like know
about it and like
the administration they like blocked me
on everything they block stall bro
like so no no
nobody on campus can watch your videos
oh well they can but like they administ
well people kept tagging the [ __ ] out of
my university
just like spamming them so i think they
didn't want to be associated with star
bro
so wait are you are you like a kind of a
vigilante figure there where they
they want to know your your identity
like are they trying to figure out your
identity
um i know i think everyone's cool with
just other people
okay i wasn't sure
yeah okay well sorrow i can tell you
were
on well on your way to success and and
fame
i think you're doing fantastic work here
and uh i wish you all the best so keep
doing your thing all right buddy
thanks for you guys i appreciate you
guys all right
all right papa bless you thanks man
what a ledge yeah what a legend legend
ledge bro ledge bro this is kind of a
legend for sure
i have that uh kate timmons with the
foot fetish story if you want to talk to
her um
this is the foot so do you want to watch
yeah let's just bring her in [ __ ] it
let's talk
okay bringing her on now so what's her
name
uh kate timmons kate
kate kate timmy hello hello
hello there so let me ask you um
you've got beautiful feet that men like
to admire is this right
yes and how did you get involved
first in you said that you would you
were at like a foot
fetish bar of some sort is that right
well
it's actually um a party that i found
through craigslist
oh you saw years ago yeah no
no i did not start it i found a
advertisement for it on craigslist
and i decided to go and check it out
and it was in the basement of a
indian restaurant that did hookah um
and i guess they rented it as like a
event space
and yeah so i guess somehow these hosts
got the word out and
foot fetish is a really big thing and a
lot of guys who would come
and pay us to lick our feet okay so
hold on back it up here for a second
okay so
so this is what goes on in the basements
of indian restaurant
okay exactly so are we
so you found a post on craigslist what
did the post say
um gosh i mean i think it was pretty
straightforward it was just kind of like
doing our
fetish party or women with good looking
feet maybe i had to send a photo or
something
and tell them what size shoes so they
so they vetted your feet and approved
you and then said
come to this indian restaurant basement
where it's all gonna go down
um yes yes and i went for a couple weeks
it was like a weekly party
and i ended up being really popular and
they invited me to come work at their
they called it the foot pad and it was
an apartment
in the west village that um
people booked times and they could come
and they could lick your feet there in
the privacy of an apartment
so are you making good money from this
or i mean i don't know are you i don't
know are you still doing it
yeah so i don't do it anymore but um i
did
i did it for about a year until actually
i ended up getting fired so
that was kind of crazy okay wait wait
i have too many questions hang on so how
much
so first of all you sit down in a chair
the guy comes do you see the guy or does
someone just like how does it work where
the guy selects you to suck on your toes
yeah so like we'd probably be sitting
around smoking hookah or something
and they would just kind of pick
whoever they like and you maybe wear
a nice pair of high heels and have your
coats done
and they would pick you and then they
kind of take your shoes off and then
they start putting your feet on their
face and it's
really kind of crazy a lot of guys like
to just get them on their head
and then put them on their face and
smell them
so um by the way can you get closer to
the the phone is a little staticky it
was better at first
yeah i apologize i think my microphone
oh that's much better
thank you i apologize no worries and so
so basically it's like a brothel where
they come in
but they just they get down with your
feet so what do you do when they're
getting down with
their your feet do you just continue to
smoke hookah
yeah you could smoke hookah or you just
kind of close your eyes
i mean some some of them might want to
talk to you it really just depends on
kind of what they're doing
like you don't want to talk i see
i was gonna say do you need to be like
pretending to
be into it or you just sit there like
whatever i
i never really pretended to be into it
but they don't really they don't get
some people don't really mind that
yeah but it doesn't really matter
they're just kind of munching down on
your toes and stuff and in their own
did you like it or you're just like you
were kind of grossed out by it
i'm kind of grossed out by it i'd say
like the handsome to
not handsome ratio was probably like one
to ten
so very few just a bunch of unattractive
in general would you describe them as
kind of weirdos in general who came to
do this
yes definitely definitely like basement
dwellers so we were in the right
environment for that
and so how much would you get paid per
per session
i think it was about 20 minutes for 10
minutes
or sorry 20 dollars per 10 minutes and
then
would they that wasn't terrible they
would sometimes pay more
for longer like what's the longest
somebody sucked on your toes
um well you would book an hour at the
footpath and that was actually like 120
an hour and then you split it with the
house
so i mean some days i'd make like five
hundred dollars there so
wow wow and i bet your feet were clean
as hell like
i bet your feet number felt so clean huh
it turns out yeah
i actually was in competition with
another girl that had big feet
and um she ended up booking a double
with me
and it wasn't on the books so she was
like well let's just
not uh pay out this money and we'll
split it and then she
told the owner and that's why i got
fired because they thought i was
stealing
why didn't you show you a narcon yeah
what was that uh because
because we both had big feet and a lot
of her regulars were
starting to see me when i got hired she
sabotaged you
she was like yeah she totally sabotaged
me and i didn't even
think of it at all it was crazy so i
went back and robbed them
and you know you went back and robbed
them
tell me about that how did that go down
okay well they were like
you're you're not allowed to come back
here like don't ever we're gonna have
security here full time
so i went out to a bar and i was like
it's two in the morning i'll just go by
the foot pad and see if anyone's there
and i like
buzzed no one was there so i used my key
i went in no one had grabbed the drop
for the day and i
ran out with like a thousand dollars oh
and i never went back that's pretty
crazy
yeah i had to change my name and
everything just for a thousand bucks you
changed your name damn
did you regret taking the money after
that no i mean for this phone call
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah you don't yeah i
don't know
yeah jeez you ever steal any no i didn't
regret it at all i never regretted it
because you know they don't pay taxes
like it was
it could have been a legal business
because there was no like um
we didn't touch them i mean i think some
of the girls probably did that but
regardless there were no foot jobs or
anything
they would say like oh uh they're gonna
send in you know like
people to try and catch you if you do it
so i was always very good about that
i i mean i was like more of a dom so i
would just kind of like stomp on guys
with like high heels and then
that's crazy it was definitely crazy and
so that that i didn't
mind so you have the link in the
description
you have big feet as i'm as i'm
understanding it that's what the guys
liked about you
pardon sorry you have big feet is that
what the guys like that you have big
feet
yeah yeah what size is your foot six
foot
oh i am a size 10.
i mean for a tall person it's pretty
normal
yeah i mean i i don't know it was big in
the foot fetish world i suppose
so wow so so what so what are you doing
these days to get by
um i'm in law school right now wow
yeah better call saul in the making it's
all good
yeah that's pretty crazy you stole have
you ever stole other stuff or are you
like
frequently did you feel like it was
technically yours it's a completely
one-time deal
but that night i just counted it over
and over i met my friends i was like
look at this
count it over and over because they knew
they knew how it was kind of like
that was my gig and it was kind of sorry
i lost my mic
um it's just kind of really upsetting to
me the way that that happened
um it was kind of what i was relying
upon at that time so
i was like you know screw these people
because they didn't even want to hear my
side of the story so
yeah [ __ ] them they deserve that yeah
exactly
um would you be willing to let zack suck
on your toes
oh my god oh um i mean
if zach wanted to suck my toes i suppose
interesting
exactly chris i even let him do it for
free
oh my god wow zach you hearing this
you know i said it before i will do
anything for the show so i will suck on
your toes yes
but wait you dude i thought he was gonna
say for once that he's not into yeah you
in los angeles what
are your new york area i'm in new york
yeah i'm in new york well we'll fly zach
out there
okay cool well thank you for sharing i
mean
yeah yeah is there any it was there any
like super weird dudes or situations you
remember you got into from the business
any dudes that would like whip it out
and i was like that's
that's not okay you know i don't know
without that go into the bathroom
um that was definitely uncomfortable if
that happened
and then there was one guy that like
wanted me to stomp
on his privates and like really absurdly
high heels kind of like movie stuff and
i was just like there's just no [ __ ]
way
i'm just not doing that so um
but in general it was all kind of weird
i mean it was all just very weird it was
not
my fetish so i never really was like
this is so cool
it was kind of like this is [ __ ]
weird i can't believe this is my life
but
the more i talked about the more
comfortable it came the people came
so you cleaned up you got cleaned up
we wish you well you did a fantastic job
out there all right yeah not just my
feet i cleaned up everything now
keep your head low you're a you're a
wanted criminal
all right yeah thank you
all right take care good luck i lost all
right bye-bye thanks
thank you wow what a call
yeah incredible fantastic you wouldn't
want to
you made it sound like you don't want to
suck her toes zack no i do want to suck
her toes
you don't yeah yeah i figured you did i
don't have a foot fetish but i'm into it
how are you into everything zach is just
he he got he broke up with his
girlfriend and now he's just [ __ ]
off the rails yeah girl i think you need
a girlfriend zach because yeah
i'm afraid that you get a little too
crazy for a disaster
and you're off the rails like this yeah
i'm having too much fun man
are you are you seeing other women
uh yeah oh how many women
um i've been on a couple dates
slept with any of them no comment
wow more than one no comment
wow any of them fancy the show
a few yeah that was supposed to be no
comment too dude
yeah big time
know just a quick update wiki feat is
back up and we are so close to number
one
oh [ __ ] let's get going people
guys just a reminder that on wiki feet
bobby lee passes this is a code red
emergency situation that we need to uh
pass bobby lee now
uh site by rating oh i'm number one
thank you guys thank you guys yeah we
did it
i know you i knew we could do it thank
you for reminding me i knew we could do
it this is a site popularity
we did it we're number one and without
knocking and bobby
exactly you guys you guys are
professionals
but here's where the real challenge
begins
popular popularity we have to knock
shawn mendes or whoever he is
off the chart yeah whatever that is
chris hemsworth
all these jokers make sense that you're
not even close
well they have got a lot of votes i mean
like
this guy who's in like sixth place
has 279 well he's got some mega feed
picks look at this guy is not shy about
his feet
nice what's with all the crazy feet
picks bro how am i supposed to compete
with that
look at this shot he's basically just
saying jerk off to my feet
why is being so weird yeah i don't know
oh maybe it's cause i'm zoomed in
weirdo weirdo look at that
yeah i have a feeling like that this guy
is actually into fit he knows what he's
doing when he takes that photo
by the way his hat looks like a wicky
feet hat
weirdo bro you're weirdo
so how many votes do i have at this
point let's see
we have um 192. you see guys come on
what what kind of armor
than that this is not army [ __ ]
in their defense it was down it was down
right as soon as i i just told him that
it's back up and i immediately went over
and got you to number one
oh good job good work guys army strong
army orbee
um this video blew my goddamn mother
loving mind ela
yeah and you are going to love it
so hang gliding
[ __ ] gliding first of all [ __ ] action
sports i'll never do it
but if you needed another excuse to do
it then here it is
okay zach is in my spirit people love
zach lately
and i agree i think zach is uh
invaluable
because he's just so honest and open i
mean
thank you i appreciate that zach's the
nicest guy i've ever met
wow no you haven't known him that long
maybe
i know enough give it some time yeah no
it's true
zack has never wronged anybody he's a
sweet [ __ ] except that he's
on the cruise any [ __ ] on somebody's
[ __ ] wall right yeah and then went
back to laughs
yeah he's a little [ __ ] up oh it's
pretty he's a good friend though he's a
good friend
but remember the girl on the cruise he
[ __ ] and then threw overboard
oh yeah totally so i guess i would
suggest
yeah he's a bad boy he's got some flaws
but he's got a good heart he's got a
good heart
i appreciate that thank you people want
the zack h3 bachelor i'm not sure if i
want to put zach no
you you promised never again well though
because ian is a sweet like
straightforward guy
who i believe sincerely looking for love
and found it
zach is just trying to sniff some feet
well no i i think i am looking for love
i just
you know at this moment probably not
but oh okay so let's wait till you're
ready to settle down yeah we'll do it
um we got a super chat from miguel
saying
hope you guys are doing good and are
okay from the california fires
don't know if it's near you and also i
like your hat ethan
thank you and you know looks pretty
thank you i just read it because you
actually gave a lot
thank you so much
the fires are really wild it's not close
to us but the air quality is bad
even here which is pretty crazy i've
lived in la my entire life it's never
been worse
it's unbelievable it's it's yeah
yesterday was freaky it was like the sky
even here it started turning like yellow
and really smoky
it's like it's overcast but there's no
clouds it's just smoke yeah that's crazy
my throat feels really irritated
not from gerd but i think from they said
their quality is really bad
that's horrible also just one more uh
super chat because i just saw it and
nate redfield hello h3 sending peace and
love all the way
from russia i'd love to have a quick
chat on the air one day papa bless well
dm uh get on the discord and dm
zach he's the yeah this should just go
to everybody
zach is the gatekeeper of the car so um
get on the discord and reach out to him
and that's the way you get on the air
thank you very much so a person here
that just alisa
just wrote that um
she she uh
worked at the zoo where harambe
was killed she worked on that wild
day the day oh wow
the day harambe left us hold on a moment
of silence
what's the difference between dead air
and silence
anything else
you want to hear you're asking us yeah i
don't know
zach's made a bunch of parody songs
about it's kind of a shame that we
didn't get to use these
you know zach made these really
fantastic in
back there was a meme ian's got a p so
bad which you haven't really used in a
while
but um zach made
two parody songs that are absolutely
incredible
and we were just we're like man we're
gonna get claimed we might get blocked
and also we were live at the time so i
was like if i go live i'm gonna get
blocked it's just [ __ ] up so now we
can actually listen to him because
all of our members this song is brought
to you
by men and we are live
what we are live because you're saying
we were
live yeah we actually uploaded and
tested it okay
i don't think they'll block we'll do it
live [ __ ] it well anyway yeah if you
catch it yeah exactly
[ __ ] it if we catch it we catch it
so anyway the first one is ian's flow
okay
but of course uh even flow by pearl jam
and
about ian's urinating habits
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
any thoughts he was dancing i noticed
aim was jamming with that
nice i saw those little
hey zach did you write all the songs or
was that just like a karaoke piece
or did you write the me no i perform the
drums were programmed but i played the
guitar the bass
wow yeah wow wow wow what a legend
fantastic stuff zach thank you
and then another one ian don't pee it
over
this one this one is even funnier what's
the original name of this song uh zach
don't dream it's over by the crowded
house
we gotta upload these i think we have to
upload these to uh
separately to the highlight channel
you need a full screen hello i don't
[Applause]
[Music]
know
[Music]
all day he might need to be in a paper
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
wow i want the whole songs out yeah i
want a full song why stop there
i can make the whole song i [ __ ] love
that one the thing is
that actually well the meme is very much
alive because we were start trying to
start today and in
he just disappears right he just goes to
the bathroom
doesn't say anything and we're all like
ian
and then it's like hey guys uh one quick
question all of a sudden he comes back
like
like we're not late we weren't all just
waiting for him
it's not all his fault but i'll blame it
all on him
it's a team effort the reason we're late
every time man those were good
we all contributed to fenway and
everything
e n it's a good thing he's passed away
and we've incinerated
yeah yeah he got what he deserved um the
people in the chat asking that that
image that was on screen we had actually
created that a while ago for a different
we had previously had a competition on
the show or not really competition but
fans of this yeah the
favorite screens yeah yeah we have we
have this graphic on the highlights
channel don't we
right because we made a compilation of
all the fan-made ian songs right and
i wanted to parody one of these so we we
kind of did a little photo shoot
here yeah i am very hyped and pleased to
introduce
annie intern big dogs
this is culture right here i love this
song
let's get your ass in here we got a lot
to talk about anyway i could do this all
day
yeah it's rewind time
it's rewind time so anyway
that's pretty much it for today yo
that's it is there any other
uh donations or calls or questions we
should address before we uh end the
episode
uh i got one from uh
sparsh bon sol i'm very sorry if i put
your name
uh with a thousand uh i think these are
rupees i think it's india i just want to
say thank you ethan ela for being such
an
uh inspiration i also suffer from gad
but you guys inspired no no
yeah i'm mixing up my words and my guess
you guys inspired me to go out and start
my own business so thank you
wow good job man don't let it win that's
all i can say
go get that don't ever let it stop and
uh
one from uh again i'm sorry if i'm
saying these names wrong
cow lore cow is k-a-o
uh yo i definitely love to share my
story of my people
shout out to the podcast with the crew
though number 27 baby
27 in the world shout out i i'm not i'm
sorry i don't know
here i'm googling it right now oh it's
an epic group in china
um well reach out to get on the discord
and reach out to zach
but we need more specific details yeah i
mean more but
yeah yeah exactly but i'd like to hear
about your people
and i'd like to tell you about my people
and uh oh alyssa this was the one you
read off and miguel i guess
i guess that's it sorry we missed
anything um sarah said we just put our
family dog down a few hours ago and this
is finally making me smile today
sorry to hear that that ain't right yeah
the dog should never die dog should live
forever
the fact that dogs only live like 10 to
15 years is a [ __ ] cruel joke that
god plays on all of us
no he's an ass look at these two i wish
they would live for like 60 years i feel
like
i feel like they should live i want them
to be at my funeral
and then like you know i want them to be
buried with me they should die when i
die
yeah right guys and then uh
luke asked does aien run ubuntu
please ubuntu what's your operating
system
i'm actually powered by well in the in
my center core i have
multiple shungite rocks oh you're
powered by shungite
oh i didn't know that was a uh didn't
know that was
used in that such a way but wow that
sounds pretty advanced
oh there's all sorts of uses for
shungite yeah
but let's talk after the show okay
uh what else hey ian do you watch porn i
know you're connected to the internet do
you watch pornography
oh whoa i i watch a lot of tech reviews
why you clear your throat
yeah why didn't clear his throat
[Laughter]
wow i thought you hated me i didn't know
you were gay
you know keep your keep your friends
close your enemies closer
[Laughter]
and then uh brady caldwell donated 50
dollars
uh canadian dollars and didn't leave a
comment so brazil send those canadian
dollars
back no i'm kidding i love you canada
rules and i thank you for the donation
uh sophia says for zach uh ten dollars
for zach's beautiful singing and
instrumental talent i
am simpin with a bunch of belle delphine
uh diego faces so
yeah e and e
whatever whatever you know the drugs you
guys know the song yeah we should throw
those up on the
on the highlights yeah i think so with
the ian bopping his head to the
low five whatever right yeah
i gotta be honest i kind of miss ian
like the real ian
uh yeah a lot of people in the chat had
those feelings too
i wish there was a way to have both of
them mm-hmm
yeah but we don't have the technology at
the moment
we literally don't have the technology
well what if ian and aion shared the
same camera
well yeah i mean of course and then he
just covers his mouth
are you committed bullet jeff dunham no
you got to commit to the bid oh
so that's it today the next podcast
we're filming
is on monday and it is let's let's give
them a tease
let's give them a tease let's show them
what's over there let's do it
show them turn your camera down uh so
my camera's actually frozen right now
which is why i haven't been cutting
myself
when we had those technical issues uh so
uh oh so we can't show up here i can
move my camera yeah we can just move the
main camera
okay all right you guys try to guess
what's going on here
[Music]
can you see it let's see oh [ __ ]
looking live behind the scenes how's the
lighting look super dark
it is very dark it's really dark
it's after dark it's good for a teaser
nice baby
thank you he's next nicest guy
that's fine a little bit more a little
bit more
yeah so that's what's going down on
monday
and it will be going up on tuesday and
i'm very excited
it's going to be insane and we'll just
see what happens
yeah let's see what happens
well that's it i mean well have a great
weekend thank you to our members that
make this possible you guys helped
support the show
you guys helped support the nation
without you members
we wouldn't be able to be making so much
content we do it for you guys you guys
enable us to do it
that we have got this great team that we
put together i'm so proud and happy and
thankful to be working with such a
talented bunch of guys
and uh sky's the limit we're 27 i'm
gunning for
uh ten episodes number one ten episodes
a week baby
ten episodes a week yeah ten episodes no
though that'll kill us but i am gunning
for five
i really do genuinely think we can do
five
yeah we'll get there eventually but four
for now was plenty once we're in the
studio we're gonna need to figure it out
but yeah once we're in the studio it's i
think gonna be a lot
easier because we'll all be in the same
space we can actually work together
instead of these constant zoom calls
what do you guys think if the on
wednesday i posted one that was
all for politics so i don't have to talk
about it in the other show
but i'd like like uh talking about
politics
and news oriented stuff so that would be
what i'm thinking would be the fifth
episode it's the quarantine episode we
quarantined the politics and it's right
i don't like it oh trump doesn't like
that makes sense
he would probably be a frequent topic
but you know it's nice to separate it
because people get sensitive about these
kinds of issues and
i think i could have like uh political
uh
entertainers figures you know there's a
lot of them on youtube
that could like go just got that kyle
kalinski you guys suggested
yeah people like there was a second
super chat that that people are saying
second and then people are begging no
please no well you don't have to watch
it that's the beauty of it right yeah i
think that would be the idea
i mean that's the point is that you
don't have to watch it if you want to
but i don't know we'll think about it
yeah it's separate it's totally separate
what dan
oh nothing i was just saying we can we
can still think about it all right well
before we log off here we're kind of off
the rails at this point
uh real quick uh uh ayush our caller
uh android 31 he donated he said i was
here from the poop call thanks again for
having me on the call it was a blast
sorry for trying to chill my channel at
the last minute understanding you guys
can't risk endorsing random channels
wait
when did he try to no he said his his uh
mime club his comments oh i was just
kidding dude it's totally fine to plug
your [ __ ]
yeah mine club go [ __ ] go watch these
geniuses perform
[Laughter]
um yeah you guys are slacking on wiki
feet man i
listen on the membership you're number
one
i'm not on popularity dan
the thing is that there's you have to
like sign up and [ __ ] so there's like a
whole process
yeah you don't want to be on wikipedia i
have to be number one across the board i
need people to actually go and be like
why is this guy number one
like people who actually go here to beat
off defeat and then like it's me and
bobby lee
but i almost have a six i almost have a
perfect six so
sierra just donated 35 hey guys i forgot
to type my message i guess she might
have donated earlier
uh it's my birthday today and i love
your glasses ela happy birthday sierra
all right this is totally off the rails
we have lost all aim and focus
thank you guys once again we love you
appreciate you have a great weekend
hope you stay safe don't catch on fire
don't catch covet don't catch on fire
don't catch covet have to be
safe social distance
and we're gonna be putting mayonnaise on
dan's dome really soon i didn't tell you
guys but i've been on a really good
diet i've been doing really good i don't
know about what after what i witnessed
yesterday maybe
whatever
all right i'm gonna all right guys we'll
see you next time all right have a great
weekend have a great weekend
ritual and e.t share a laugh with the
ringer see y'all love
jimmy lee they said we wouldn't come
back but we always do embrace from the
ashes like the peanuts on the flex back
to two
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h to the
three
three three three you're watching h 2 3
3
3 3 you're watching h 2 3 3 3
[Music]
you